If you for a moment believe that Donald Trump's
authoritarian tendencies were all fun and
games, it is just become very, very real.
As Donald Trump is now publicly threatening
to withhold money from Michigan if they decide
to vote by mail and also threatening the state
of Nevada over vote by mail.
So in the last three to four weeks, as Corona
virus has been raging, vote by mail logically
has become a really big deal.
When we think about we've got a presidential
election.
We have thirty five Senate elections in November.
When we think about people voting, when we
think about voter disenfranchisement, we immediately
talk about vote by mail.
And that's been a growing conversation for
the last month or so.
Donald Trump doesn't want you to vote by mail
because he knows that if more people vote,
it's very, very bad for him.
That's it's plain and simple.
I mean, we we can go into more about it, but
that's the story.
Trump knows more people voting is not good
for him in November.
He sees the polls and he knows he need any
voter suppression tactic he can get.
He has couched it as vote by mail, makes fraud
easier.
This is something we've debunked.
250 million ballots have been cast by mail
in the last 20 years.
On average, there are seven or eight individual
issues of vote by mail fraud per year.
That's not seven or eight percent.
That's not seven or eight per state.
That's seven or eight issues per year nationally
with absentee ballots.
It is statistically as close to zero as you
can get.
Well, Donald Trump is now becoming an authoritarian
nightmare that we always feared he would be.
When it comes to this issue, tweeting yesterday,
quote, Michigan sends absentee ballot applications
to 7.7 million people ahead of primaries and
the general election.
This was done illegally and without authorization
by a rogue secretary of state.
I will ask to hold up funding to Michigan
if they want to go down this voter fraud path.
Now, there's a couple really important things
to understand here.
One is in the tweet.
Trump says Michigan is doing something illegal
by sending absentee ballot applications.
Earlier in the day, Trump tweeted.
Michigan's doing something illegal by sending
people absentee ballots.
Now, that's not what Michigan is doing.
And the Michigan governor corrected him.
Trump deleted the tweet, replaced it with
an identical, identical one that says it's
illegal to send everybody an absentee ballot
application.
Why do we care about that detail?
The reason we care about it is because of
the rules that Michigan has now.
I really want to be very clear about this.
There would not be anything illegal in the
way Trump is claiming about sending everybody
an absentee ballot, but it would go away,
go against Michigan's established rules for
absentee ballots.
The rules are you need to request one.
You can't just be sent an absentee ballot.
So importantly, Michigan is sending everybody
an application for an absentee ballot.
They want to vote in person, presumably.
But as far as the plan is right now, they
would still be able to do it if they don't
want to vote in person.
They can submit their request for an absentee
ballot and they would be sent one.
There is nothing illegal about that.
Now, Kaili McEnany, Trump's press secretary,
was asked multiple times during yesterday's
press briefing.
Trump used the word illegal.
What exactly is the law that's being broken?
She said, go talk to the Trump campaign, which,
of course, makes absolutely no, no, no sense
at all.
It's not just Michigan where Donald Trump
is doing this.
Trump also tweeting about Nevada.
Quote, State of Nevada thinks that they can
send out illegal vote by mail ballots, creating
a voter fraud scenario for the state and the
U.S..
They can't.
If they do, I think I can hold up funds to
the state.
Sorry, but you must not cheat in elections.
This is not cheating.
Okay.
This is a ruse.
And Donald Trump is creating a virulent sic
army of ignorant Trump ists who are just repeating
these talking points without even understanding
them.
It's illegal to do this.
Vote by mail is a fraud.
I really need people to understand the primary
crux of this story.
We have states rights in this country.
Listen to me sounding like a conservative.
Trump touts federalism.
Federalism means states rights.
Federalism means anything that the federal
government doesn't specifically have a duty
to do.
The power to do it is by default the power
of the states to decide for themselves.
We don't have one federal election in the
United States for president.
We have a bunch of states.
Each runs their own election.
That's the constitution.
That's federalism.
There is nothing here that would allow the
federal government to dictate how a state.
Runs their election.
Now, if you have truly a constitutional issue
of disenfranchisement or something like that,
you might see a case be appealed all the way
to the Supreme Court.
But this is Trump's want to be dictator coming
out.
Michigan allows for absentee voting for any
reason.
Ever since 2018, that passed 66 with a 66
percent majority.
It's in the state constitution.
This is federalism.
This is the law.
Michigan is having major flood issues right
now.
Trump is essentially threatening people's
lives by saying, I won't send you money if
you do vote by mail.
And that is, of course, a decision that Michigan
is 100 percent allowed to make outside the
United States.
They are watching this in horror.
I got an e-mail from a viewer in Europe saying,
David, isn't this fascism? Trump is attacking
the sovereignty of a state voting system that
is enshrined in federalism.
They are allowed to make decisions about how
they will vote, what is happening to the United
States.
I wish I could tell you it is a tragedy.
It is a nightmare.
And I hate to say it.
But once again, I don't know that Trump will
be held accountable for these threats in any
way other than other than if we vote him out
in November.